time now to take a look at uh cal
quantrill who will make the start
tonight he'll be the northeast ohio
forward dealers indian starting pitcher
quattro coming off a very good start out
in oakland where he went five innings
allowed just four hits in one run that
one run came with two outs in the first
inning other than that he was uh very
very good so we'll see how he handles
the raise tonight one on one out here is
wander franco
and the center that's going to be a base
hit mercado
makes the pick up arose harenda advances
to second
wander franco has a base hit dude he's
going to get his wish
the one-two
drop him out looking fastball bottom of
the zone
second out of the inning and a big one
for cal quantrill yeah i made a very
good pitch set it up
by throwing that 02
fastball away
wendell pops it up foul ground playable
for jose ramirez
and the inning is over so cuatro works
around a walk and a knock the rays do
not score the indians coming to bed
tonight it's going to be luis pitino
making his return to the big club he
will make he be making his fifth start
for tampa bay record one and two era of
4.87 more than a strikeout in inning
does a nice job of limiting walks
and a little tapper plays gonna be to
first with the toss
and he pops him up
that's joey wendell
and two gone after that lead-off single
the game of that series and takes a big
swing comes up empty cleveland will
leave a man in second we go to the
second inning no score
number nine hit her oscar mercado bottom
of the third no score
there's a liner to left field get down
it is a fair ball into the corner and on
his way to second with the leadoff
double is oscar mercado
they're just going to intentionally walk
ramirez
in this situation
and early in the game they're going to
take their chances with the big man
we've seen this happen before and the
big man made somebody pay
there's a ball clobbered deep left field
it is gone a home run
it just kept climbing and barely cleared
the 19-foot wall
for a two-out three-run laser
and the indians have a three-nothing
lead home run number 17 for the franimal
well guess what he didn't throw that
same slider he did the pitch before
and brad mill does it again
bad at 109. look at that thing spun it
stayed up out over the plate he knew it
he thought it might hit the top of the
wall but and he's so strong he gets out
in a hurry
here comes
line drive to right field
and past the diving right fielder
johnson all the way into the corner and
he has to go chase it at the wall diaz
around second should make it to third
without a problem and he does and the
rays get a man to third with only one
out
he's halfway to the cycle
single and now a triple his first triple
of the season is
daniel johnson out there in right field
kind of got caught
in between didn't know
whether or not he should go for it or
not go for it and then
the hesitation on both
although he ended up costing him so
yandy diaz with the triple here his kk
got it to a 3-2 count last time and hit
back to the mall meyer and the pitch
there's a drive high in the air to lift
it'll get a man in as ramirez drifting
back and under it makes the catch diaz
tags heads for home here meyer with a
sacrifice fly knocking in yandy diaz and
the raiser on the board it's three to
one cleveland well there is so far they
can manufacture a run here you got the
base hit you stole second you moved him
over now get him in
is it deep enough right field
i don't think so harold tags he's gonna
try here's the throw and it's up the
line he is saved
tribe comes right back
and restores their three-run cushion
austin hench's rbi number 14 with the
sac fly
it's that guy to make a good throw
because harold is gonna challenge him
and it wasn't deep
and the throw is offline if it's online
you're gonna get him but you see it's
offline he gets in easily good hustle
and you can see
lau is not deep at all but he plays some
infield some outfield but they
harold runs his way into another run for
the indians
tell you why they do it he's going
and a swing of the best throw down
in time got him strike him out throw out
double play
[Applause]
in the league so he throws a fastball
right by him and it's a nice pick by
rosario and he gets him down and it
looks like he got him on the on the shin
before his foot gets in there he kind of
slowed himself down on that slide yeah
chopped up the middle ahmed cuts it off
throws him out
and another goosing from cow quantrill
[Applause]
has fouled out in a fly ball to left
some strange at-bats some plays in the
field there's a high fly back into deep
rights got a chance gonna be over the
head of johnson bounding off the wall
mejia extra bases he's headed to third
and he is in there standing with the
three-base hit
his second triple
of the year
as well we talked about it earlier for a
catcher he can move but what was daniel
johnson doing on this route
i mean nowhere near that baseball he
tracked it all the way back and that's a
good three four feet behind it
that's a hot shot down to first
pitcher will cover and crossing the
plate mejia and the raves do get